AT ONE TWENTY NINE THANK YOU --
GOVERNMENT AT ITS BEST.
MADAM SECRETARY WILL YOU CALL
THE ROLL SENATORS BATES.
BATES HERE MINING.
MORNING HERE ROUGH ROUGH HERE
WILL ATKINS HERE HAPPENS HERE
THANK YOU AND FOR THE RECORD --
UNFORTUNATELY MISTER WILL CALLED
ME TODAY HE IS ILL -- SO THAT
WAS NOT SOMETHING OF COURSE THAT
HE PLANNED SO -- I HOPE HE GETS
BETTER SOON -- LET ME SEE IF WE
CAN.
ESTABLISH A CONSENT AGENDA WITH
ITEMS TO BILL REFERRALS ITEMS
THREE AND FOUR WITCHER FLOOR A
KNOWLEDGE MINTS.
THANK YOU SENATOR ROTH -- MADAM
SECRETARY.
SENATORS BATES BATES I MORNING
MORNING I ROSS.
ROSS I WILL LOOK ACTIONS FIND A
CONCISE OKAY THAT PASSES FOR
ZERO WITH MR WILL ABSENT.
LET ME GO AHEAD AND CALL OUR
FIRST.
APPOINTEE FORWARD MR TRYING TO
GO -- TO WHO IS BEING APPOINTED
OR HAS BEEN APPOINTED BY THE
GOVERNOR TO THE CALIFORNIA
GAMING CONTROL COMMISSION.
MR TOO IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE WHOEVER MIGHT BE WITH
YOU THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE MAKE YOUR OPENING
COMMENTS.
AND THEN WE WILL GO RIGHT TO
CONVERSATION OF THE COMMITTEE
WELCOME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE -- I
WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE MY
LOVELY WIFE -- WHO'S HERE TODAY --
TRICIA TELL SEES RATHER.
WELCOME.
AND UNFORTUNATELY OUR SON --
HE'S A JUNIOR A JESUIT HIGH
SCHOOL CANNOT BE HERE TODAY
BECAUSE IT'S TOWARDS THE END OF
THE SEMESTER AND SO.
A LOT OF WORK FOR HIM TO DO HAS
PROJECTS AND AP TESTS SO --
AGRARIAN IDEAL ENGINE STUDENT IS
WHAT YOU'RE TELLING A YES YES
THANK YOU -- I THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR ALL YOUR TIME -- PRESIDENT
PRO TEM SECONDS AND
DISTINGUISHES MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE RULES COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY.
MY NAME IS TRYING -- TO AND I'M
A COMMISSIONER ON THE CALIFORNIA
GAMING CONTROL COMMISSION.
I HAVE A SIDE I HAVE SPENT MOST
OF MY PROFESSIONAL CAREER
WORKING TO PROTECT THE INTERESTS
OF MY LOCAL COMMUNITY.
AS A PEACE OFFICER AND IT HAS
BEEN A GREAT HONOR [inaudible]
TO SERVE.
AS A COMMISSIONER ON THE
CALIFORNIA GAMING CONTROL
COMMISSION.
WORKING TO PROTECT ALL
CALIFORNIA.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DRAW FOR MY
PRIOR.
EXPERIENCE.
AS A PEACE OFFICER.
AND HELP PRESERVE THE INTEGRITY
OF THE GAMING INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN A
CHALLENGING AND REWARDING
EXPERIENCE.
AND I WOULD LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE -- THIS GREAT
STATE FOR THE NEXT SEVERAL YEARS.
I HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF WORKING
WITH A VERY DEDICATED.
AND HARDWORKING STAFF AT THE
COMMISSION.
AS WELL AS THOUGHTFUL AND
RESPECTFUL COMMISSIONER
COLLEAGUES.
WHO CONSIDER EACH IMPORTANT
DECISION?
BEFORE US WITH DUE CARE AND
CONSIDERATION.
MY WORK TO UPHOLD THE MANDATE
GIVEN TO THE COMMISSION.
WHILE ALSO ENSURING THAT EACH
APPLICANT.
WISHING TO WORK IN THIS INDUSTRY
IS GIVEN FOR DUE PROCESS.
AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE THE
STORY.
WHAT THE COMMISSION [inaudible]
WITH INTEGRITY.
IN THE INDUSTRY AS MY PRIMARY
GOAL I WILL CONTINUE TO BUILD
UPON.
AND GIRL RELATIONSHIP WITH.
THOSE IN BOTH THE CARD ROOM.
AND TRAVEL INDUSTRY.
AND TO INCREASE OUT REACH TO
APPLICANTS.
WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS.
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SENATOR RUNNING CAN I START WITH
YOU TODAY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND THANK
YOU MR TOE CONGRATULATIONS ON
YOUR CONTINUE TO WORK ON THE
COMMISSION IN HERE -- NOMINATION
TO CONTINUE I ALSO WANNA IN
KNOWLEDGE AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PUBLIC SERVICE IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND I BELIEVE PHILA
LAW ENFORCEMENT POSITION.
IN THE COMMISSION THANK YOU
SENATOR.
IN WE YOU SHARED A LOT IN OUR
CONVERSATION -- YESTERDAY AND I
APPRECIATED YOUR TAKING THE TIME.
A COUPLE OF POINTS THAT I THINK
WOULD BE OF INTEREST TO OUR
COMMITTEE.
WHICH IS THE QUESTION OF THE
PROSPECT OF ONLINE SPORTS
BETTING IN CALIFORNIA IN HOMES
NOT NEAR PURVIEW TO DECIDE
WHETHER OR NOT.
THAT IS LEGALIZED I DID ASK YOU
WHAT YOU FELT THE CAPACITY WAS
OF THE COMMISSION. TO OVERSEE
THAT SHOULD.
SHOULD IT BE LEGALIZED AT SOME
POINT IN MAYBE YOU COULD SHARE
SOME OF YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT.
THANK YOU SENATOR -- AS A
COMMISSION IF THE LEGISLATURE --
DECIDE THAT -- THE COMMISSION --
WILL BE THE AGENCY TO CREATE --
REGULAR REGULATIONS AS A
REGULATORY BODY.
WE ARE ABLE AND WILLING.
TO SIT DOWN WITH THE LEGISLATURE.
AND OR PINIONS AND WITHIN OUR
EXPERTISE BECAUSE I KNOW OUR
STAFF IS.
TREMENDOUS SHOULD THEY HAVE
TREMENDOUS EXPERTISE -- GREAT
LEADERSHIP AND WE HAVE BEEN
MONITORING EVER SINCE -- THE
CITRIX SUPREME COURT A LAST YEAR
A MAKE THAT RULING -- TO
PROHIBIT A SPORTS BETTING OF
DEPEND ON THE STATE.
AND SO -- WITH THAT ALL THOUGHTS
IS -- THERE'S MANY CONSIDERATION
THAT -- I BELIEVE THE
LEGISLATURE -- WOULD HAVE -- TO
CONSIDER -- WHO CAN WHO CAN
OFFER SPORTS BETTING?
HOW'S THE APPLICATION PROCESS
GONNA GO -- WHO WILL HAVE OF
COMPLIANCE -- AND BACKGROUND --
ASPECT OF THAT WILL BE -- THE
BARREL OF CAMERA CONTROL -- WHAT
KIND OF SPORTS BETTING OF CAN WE
WOULD -- YOU NEED TO CONSIDER --
WOULD IT BE -- SOMETHING TO
CONSIDER OF SPORTS BETTING IS
WOULD BE -- REAL LIVE -- AS IT'S
HAPPENING I CAN'T THINK OF THE
WORD BUT IT'LL ALERT FOR
INSTANCE -- FOOTBALL GAME -- CAN.
SHOULD WE CONSIDER ALLOW.
BEDDING -- TO OCCUR DURING THE
GAMES -- HAVE TIME AFTER
HALFTIME THE SECOND HALF WOULD
WOULD THAT BE CONSIDERED -- THE
TAX -- SCHEDULE.
HOW WOULD THAT BE SO THERE ARE
MANY THINGS THAT THE THE THE
LEGISLATURE -- SHOULD CONSIDER --
AND WE WOULD BE.
ORDER HAPPY -- TO TO GIVE OUR EX
EXPERTISE OPINION AND AND WORKED
DILIGENTLY WITH THE LEGISLATURE.
THANK YOU AND I APPRECIATE THAT
AND AGAIN WHILE I KNOW THAT'S
NOT BEFORE YOU AT THIS MOMENT --
I JUST FOUND YOUR KNOWLEDGE IN.
THE EXPANSIVE CONSIDERATIONS
THAT WE WOULD WANT -- TO HAVE
BEFORE SO THANK YOU FOR THAT AND
THEN -- YOU REFERENCED I NOTES
THE BUREAU OF ENFORCEMENT THAT'S
IN CHARGE OF ENFORCEMENT MATTERS
THE COMMISSION REVIEWS.
CITATIONS SIR LICENSE ISSUES.
WE ALSO SPOKE OF THE THE INDIAN
CASINOS THE COMPAQ'S.
AND HOW THEY ARE IN CHARGE OF
THEIR OWN LICENSING OF A CERTAIN
LEVEL OF EMPLOYEES AND IT'S ONLY
AT CERTAIN LEVELS FOR THE
COMMISSION HAS OVERSIGHT AND ONE
OF YOU TO SHARE BRIEFLY.
THAT DISTINCTION AND WHETHER YOU
THINK THERE ARE ANY CONCERNS OF
MAYBE LATERAL TRANSFERS BETWEEN
DIFFERENT -- CASINO GAMING
FACILITIES THAT MAYBE SOMEBODY'S
BEEN TERMINATED AT ONE BUT
THERE'S NOTHING IN FRONT OF YOUR
COMMISSION.
THAT WOULD GIVE RISE TO REVIEW
TO WORK SOMEWHERE ELSE.
SURE THANK YOU -- SENATOR -- THE
PAYROLL -- AND OUR COMMISSION
HAS A VERY LIMITED --
INVOLVEMENT WITH THE THE TRIBAL --
BECAUSE EVERY TRIBAL HAS THEIR
OWN GAMING COMMISSION.
AND THEY ARE IN CHARGE -- AND
HAS THE UTHORITY TO HIRE --
EVERY TO EVERY -- OF THEIR
EMPLOYEES EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
THE EMPLOYEES THEY THEY HAVE THE
AUTHORITY -- THE ONLY TIME ONE
AND OF COURSE THERE ARE --
APPLIANCE AND INVESTIGATIVE
UNITS WOULD DO BACKGROUND
CONDUCT BACKGROUNDS -- ON THOSE
INDIVIDUAL THAT THEY HIRE.
AND THEY HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
GRANT LICENSES -- TO IN VISUAL
DATA IF THEY DEEM TO TO BE
SUITABLE -- THE ONLY TIME WHEN.
THE STATE WHEN WE GET INVOLVED
AND THAT.
pPROMOTION TO A SUPERVISORY
POSITION WHICH WE CALL IT THE
KEY EMPLOYEE POSITION.
AND THEN THAT APPLICANT.
IS REQUIRED TO SUBMIT -- STATE
APPLICATION AND THAT'S WHEN THE
COMMISSION -- BECOMES INVOLVED
NOW.
KEEP IN MIND THAT THE BOY HE HAS
ALREADY BEEN LICENSED BY THE THE
TRIBAL CASINO -- BUT WE AS A
NEGOTIATING A COMPACT -- WELL
THE TROUBLE NEGOTIATED COMPACT --
WE TWO OF THE THE THE THE MERYL
WILL CONDUCT -- BACKGROUNDS ON
THAT INDIVIDUAL FOR KEY EMPLOYEE
POSITION -- WE WITH FIGHTING
ONLY THAT WE WOULD FIND A
SUITABLE.
WHETHER THAT EMPLOYEE IS
SUITABLE OR NOT NOT TO GRANT A
LICENSE -- THAT'S UP -- TO THE
TRIBAL CASINO ABOUT HIMSELF
HOWEVER THIS IS A A A A
DISTINCTION BETWEEN -- A TRIBAL
MEMBER.
AND A NON TRIBAL MEMBERS -- WHEN
WE FIND -- THE PERSON IS
SUITABLE OR NOT.
IF IT IF THAT POOR EMPLOYEE IS A
TRIBAL MEMBER.
THE THE THE TROUBLE IS NOT.
BUYING INTO A TWO OF TECH ALL
RECOMMENDATION.
DATE BECAUSE OF THE NEGOTIATING
COMBAT THEY CAN HIRE -- THEY CAN
FALL GO ALL RECOMMENDATION
WHETHER WE ARE IF IT'S IF WE SHE
SAID DENY THAT PERSON IS
SUITABLE.
TO THE TRIBAL CAUGHT THE TRIBAL
CAN -- HIGHER THAT THE POLICE A
REGARDLESS OF WHAT.
NOW IT'S DIFFERENT WITH THE NON
TRIBAL MEMBER.
AT ONCE THE THE SUITABILITY IS
FOUNDED -- WELL WE DENY THAT
PERSON.
THEN THE TRIBAL CASINO HAS TO
TERMINATE.
THAT EMPLOYEE.
SO THAT THERE'S A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE TWO AND THAT'S A
PROBLEM THE ONLY TIME WHEN WE
GET INVOLVED IN -- BUT THE
TRIBAL. EIGHT ONE AGAIN I
APPRECIATE -- YOUR THOROUGH
COMMAND OF OF THIS OVERSIGHT
POSITION I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR US SENATOR
BATES.
THANK YOU AND NOT LET ME BEGIN --
MISTRAL BY CONGRATULATING YOU ON
AS STELLAR -- YEARS OF SERVICE --
IN MAZING BACK TO NINETEEN
EIGHTY FOUR AND I NOICED ON
BRING YOUR RESUME WHICH IS VERY
IMPRESSIVE THAT YOU STARTED IN A
GANG SUPPRESSION UNIT.
YEAH. NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR AND
SHORTLY AFTER THAT MY HOME CITY
INCORPORATED IN ONE OF THE FIRST
THINGS THAT WE DID WAS STARTING
UNIT LIKE THAT WITH THE
SHERIFF'S RECOMMENDATION I
WONDERED IF THAT IT COME FROM
PERHAPS WHAT YOU HAD ALREADY
BEEN DOING IN SACRAMENTO BECAUSE
IT WAS SOMETHING.
THAT WAS OF GREAT CONCERN AT
THAT TIME IN OUR COMMUNITY
OUTSIDE OF GANGS ARE
PROLIFERATING OUT AMONGST OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE SO.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE THERE
AND CERTAINLY ALL THE WAY
THROUGH IT FOR A QUITE
IMPRESSIVE THANK YOU SENATORI
DO HAVE A QUICK QUESTION FOR YOU
IF FOR ABOUT EIGHTY EIGHT EIGHTY
AND THE NEW TRIBAL NATION
GRANDPARENT ALL.
AND YOU'RE RESPONSIBLE FOR
IMPLEMENTING THE REGULATIONS ARE
IMPLEMENTING OFF.
THE MEASURE OFF HOW ARE WE DOING
ARE WE MOVING FORWARD WE HAVE
THINGS ARE READY TO GO OR IN
PROCESS OF HAVING TO ADDRESS AT
THANK YOU -- THE AB AT -- WAS
PASSED LAST YEAR IN SEPTEMBER OF
BY THE LEGISLATURE.
OF THE GIFTS OF THE STATE -- IT
REQUIRES -- AN APPOINTMENT OF
NINE MEMBERS. TO THIS PANEL --
TO WHICH SEVEN ARE VOTING
MEMBERS AND TWO ARE NON VOTING
MEMBERS ALTERNATE -- PELLETS
APPOINTED BY THE GOVERNORS --
TROUBLE ADVISER.
THE COMMISSION HAS A HAS A
LIMITED.
SHIN ON THIS ALTHOUGH WE WE ALL
THE TRUSTEE OF THE THE THE THE
FUN.
BUT THIS.
NEW PANEL WILL BE THE AUTHORITY --
THE PANEL -- IS RESPONSIBLE --
TO DEVELOP -- PROCESSES AND AND
WHOSE HOW IS IT GOING TO BE --
IN THE FUTURE WHO WHO COULD GET
THE APPOINTMENT HOW APPOINTMENTS --
CONDUCTED AND APPLICATIONS ARE
RECEIVED IN OF THAT NATURE --
THE PANEL WILL CONVENE FOR THE
FIRST TIME -- I BELIEVE MAY
SEVENTEENTH OF THIS OF THIS
MONTH.
AND THAT WOULD BE MOVING FORWARD
WITH -- ARE THERE A
RESPONSIBILITY AND AND START TO
DEVELOPING POLICIES FOR THAT.
SO IT'S IN IT'S IN THE BEGINNING
PHASE THEN YES IT IS AGAIN WE
HAVE VERY LIMITED ROLE WE WE
HAVE A AND MINISTRY OF SUPPORT --
ROLE IN THAT AND WE DON'T MAKE
ANY RECOMMENDATION -- ONLY THAT --
NINE PANEL MEMBERS.
THANK YOU WILL BE ANXIOUS TO
HEAR HOW THAT GOES FORWARD
BECAUSE IT WAS AN IMPORTANT US
DOWN.
I IN TERMS OF THE REVENUE
SHARING THEM -- FOR THE NON
GAMING TRIBES SO APPRECIATE THAT
AND I THINK THE OUTSIDE YET FOR
ME -- MADAM CHAIR AND THANK YOU
AGAIN CONGRATULATIONS AND I
CERTAINLY WILL BE OUT.
VERY -- SUPPORTIVE OF YOUR
NOMINATION AND YOUR APPOINTMENT
WITH THE CENTER.
THANK YOU SENATOR US SENATOR
ROTH THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR SIR
CONGRATULATIONS.
I HAVE A ABSOLUTELY NO QUESTIONS
AND I'D BE DELIGHTED TO MOVE
OUR CONFIRMATION AT THE
APPROPRIATE TO POINT TIME THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU SENATOR ROTH THANK YOU
SENATOR ROTH LET ME ON NOW
INVITE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO
ARE HERE IN SUPPORT TO COME
FORWARD [inaudible]
IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY THAT'S A GOOD SIGN --
CENTER ROTH YOU HAD REQUESTED.
THANK YOU OURMAN SECRETARY
SENATORS BATES HI MATES I MINING.
MORNING I ROSS ROSS I WILL.
ATKINS HI BACK INSIDE THAT IS --
UNANIMOUS FOUR ZERO WITH AN
ABSENCE -- CONGRATULATIONS
CONGRATULATIONS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE NEWS AND THE STAFF AND FOR
YOUR ATTENTION TO THIS MATTER
AND I TRULY APPRECIATED AND I
WILL.
CONTINUE TO DO THE BEST JOB THAT
I CAN FOR THE SOME OF THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA THANK YOU WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LET ME SEE I INVITE MS JENKINS
JONES FORWARD AND ASK YOU TO
START BY TELLING ME HOW TO SAY
YOUR FIRST NAME SO THAT I GET IT
RIGHT.
ADRIA VERY NICE THANK YOU.
I WILL BUY INVITE YOU TO AS WELL
INTRODUCE FOLKS WHO OBVIOUSLY
ARE HERE TO SUPPORT YOU.
AND THEN GO AHEAD WITH YOUR
COMMENTS AND AND THEN WE'LL GET
RIGHT INTO IT WELCOME.
THANK YOU THANK YOU WELL GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR ACTIONS AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
I WOULD LIKE TO INTRODUCE MY
FAMILY WHO ARE HERE TO SUPPORT
ME FIRST MY MOTHER ELIZABETH
BREWER.
I RETIRED CIVIL SERVANT FROM
CORRECTIONS MY DAUGHTER ELENA
JONES AND MY COUSIN TANYA BURR
WERE.
ALSO IN ATTENDANCE IS A HOST OF
COLLEAGUES IN FRANCE FROM GOV
OPS AGENCY CALAIS CHAR AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
IT IS MY PLEASURE TO BE HERE
TODAY FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF
MY APPOINTMENT OF CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
HUMAN.
RESOURCES I AM GRATEFUL FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY USE MY THIRTY YEARS
OF STATE X. SERVICE AND
EXPERIENCE IN HUMAN RESOURCES TO
CONTRIBUTE TO MAKING A
DIFFERENCE IN STATE CIVIL
SERVICE.
AND CALIFORNIA AT LARGE.
MY CAREER IN STATE SERVICE BEGAN
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX WORKING
AS AN OFFICE ASSISTANT IN THE
MAIL ROOM WITH A STATE
COMPENSATION INSURANCE FUND.
I SPENT TWENTY THREE YEARS OF MY
STATE CAREER AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE I HAVE BEEN IN HR FOR
OVER TWENTY FIVE YEARS IN
NINETEEN OF THOSE YEARS IN
LEADERSHIP ROLES.
KELLY CHAR IS THE CENTRAL HUMAN
RESOURCES AGENCY FOR STATE
GOVERNMENT AND A LARGE PART OF
OUR FUNCTION IS TO REPRESENT THE
GOVERNOR AS AN EMPLOYER.
IN ALL MATTERS CONCERNING STATE
EMPLOYER EMPLOYEE RELATIONS
THERE ARE MANY CHALLENGING HUMAN
RESOURCES MANAGEMENT ISSUES
FACING CALIFORNIA TODAY.
AS CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR ONE OF
MY GOALS IS TO ENSURE THAT THE
CALIFORNIA CIVIL SERVICE
WORKFORCE ACCURATELY REFLECTS
THE DIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
POPULATION.
CALIFORNIA MST LEAD THE WAY AS
A MODEL FOR PROGRESSIVE IN LIKE
THE GOVERNMENT IN THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY.
THIS APPOINTMENT WILL MAKE ME
THE FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN.
CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR APPOINTED
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN
RESOURCES THIS IS A MONUMENTAL.
A MOMENT FOR MY FAMILY.
AS WELL AS IT WILL SHOW
DIVERSITY IN LEADERSHIP WITHIN
STATES SERVICE NOT ONLY AS A
WOMAN LEADER BUT FROM THE ASPECT
OF UPWARD MOBILITY.
INSPIRATION AND HOPE FOR OTHERS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HERE TODAY AND I'M HAPPY TO
ADDRESS ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SENATOR ROTH LET'S START WITH
YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
A MAN DIRECTOR CONGRATULATIONS
THANK YOU.
YOU KNOW IN AN EARLIER LIFE --
OF MINE IN THIS HOUSE I HAD
RESPONSIBILITY -- FOR OVERSIGHT
OVER -- INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
PROJECTS -- INCLUDING THE
CONTROLLERS PROJECT -- HAVING TO
DO WITH THE PAYROLL SYSTEM AND
AND THE LIKE FOR OUR CALIFORNIA
POLICE.
AND DURING THAT -- OVERSIGHT
EXPERIENCE THAT I HAD A AS I
RECALL ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT
WAS IDENTIFIED WAS THE IN TERMS
OF AN EXPLANATION FOR WHY THE
PROJECT WAS SO HARD.
WAS THE COMPLEXITY OF OUR PAY
SYSTEMS A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
TYPES OF PAY THAT PEOPLE RECEIVE.
OVER STATE GOVERNMENT THAT MADE
IT VERY VERY COMPLICATED.
AND I I KNOW THAT YOU WERE IN IN
IN BURKE IN AN EFFORT.
TO ELIMINATE OBSOLETE
CLASSIFICATIONS TO SIMPLIFY
CLASSIFICATINS.
AND IN OTHER WORDS TO MAKE OUR
CALIFORNIA SYSTEM PERHAPS
INCLUDING HOPEFULLY OUR PAY
SYSTEM.
A LITTLE EASIER TO DEAL WITH HOW
ARE YOU HOW ARE YOU COMING WITH
THAT EFFORT THAT VERY IMPORTANT
EFFORT.
ACTUALLY -- CALLIE CHAR HAS HAD
MUCH SUCCESS WITH THE CLASS
CONSOLIDATION PROJECT.
OUR BIGGEST PROJECT WITH THE I.
T. CONSOLIDATION THAT WE DID
BACK IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN WHAT WE
TOOK ABOUT TWENTY
CLASSIFICATIONS AND BROUGHT THEM
DOWN THE NIGHT -- WE ARE ALSO
WORKING -- IN THE CLASS
CONSOLIDATION CURRENTLY FOR THE
GENERAL THIS CLASSIFICATION
WHICH WILL PROBABLY AFFECT ABOUT
FORTY THOUSAND A STATE EMPLOYEES
BRING IT ABOUT THIRTY FIVE
CLASSIFICATIONS DOWN TO ABOUT --
EIGHTEEN SO WE ARE DILIGENTLY
WORKING ON THAT PROJECT -- IT IS
CONSTANTLY MOVING AND IT'S DOING
ACTUALLY VERY WELL.
EXCELLENT.
I ALSO NOTED IN THE REVIEW OF
THE MATERIAL THAT WE WERE
PROVIDED THAT YOU ARE EMBARKED
ON AN EFFORT TO FIELD.
ON INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY
PROJECT TO TRACK DISCRIMINATION
AND HARASSMENT CLAIMS.
OR COMPLAINTS AND HOW IS THAT
GOING.
ACTUALLY THAT IS ACTUALLY GOING.
YOU WILL TOO THE DISCRIMINATION
COMPLAINT TRACKING SYSTEM
PROJECT -- WE ARE LOOKING TO
COMPLETE THAT PROJECT BY JULY.
TWENTY NINETEEN OF AT THAT TIME
FROM THERE WILL BE TRAINING
DEPARTMENTS WHEN THE SYSTEM AND
WE WILL BE ENTERING.
INFORMATION INTO THE SYSTEM
JANUARY.
TWENTY TWENTY SO ONE OF THE
ISSUES THAT -- OCCASIONALLY.
A WAS IDENTIFIED DURING THE
VARIOUS IT PROJECTS THAT I HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO EXPERIENCE
HERE.
I HAD TO DO WAS ON BOARDING OF
OF STAFF AND EMPLOYEES ARE YOU --
MAYBE YOU ANSWERED THIS IN YOUR
LAST STATEMENT BUT ARE YOU IN
TE PROCESS OF OF OF DOING THE
ON BOARDING NOW GETTING THE
STAFF READY.
TO ASSUME RESPONSIBILITY WHEN
THE SYSTEM GOES LIVE AT THAT
WON'T START TILL JULY AUGUST.
FOR THE ON BOARDING FOR THE
DISCRIMINATION COMPLAINT
TRACKING SEX ON WHY I LOOK
FORWARD -- TO HEARING REPORTS ON
HOW THAT GOES IT SOUNDS LIKE
YOU'VE GOT EVERYTHING WELL IN
HAND AND YOUR QUALIFICATIONS ARE
SUPERB AND ONCE AGAIN AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME I LOOK FORWARD
TO MOVING YOUR CONFIRMATION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
BATES.
THANK YOU ON NEWS JANE CAN.
SO WE HAD SUCH A GOOD
CONVERSATION WHEN YOU'RE IN MY
OFFICE I THINK THAT I'M NOT
GONNA HAVE ANY MORE QUESTIONS
FOR YOU YOU HAVE A A SUPERB.
RESUME AND CERTAINLY ON THE
QUESTIONS I ASKED FOCUSED ON THE
RETIREMENT WAVE -- THAT WAS A
BIG ISSUE BECAUSE WE'VE TALKED-FACE THAT AND NOT SOME OF THE
ORGANIZATIONS AND ASSIGNMENTS
THAT I'VE HAD YOU HAVE THAT TO A
CERTAIN THE RECRUITMENT.
FOCUSED ON OUT SO I'M I'M VERY
COMFORTABLE TO CONGRATULATE YOU
AND BE SUPPORTIVE OF YOUR
NOMINATION WE HAVE A VOTE THANK
YOU AGAIN.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND ALSO
ON OFFER MY CONGRATULATIONS I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND ONE THING I GLEANED FROM OUR
CONVERSATION.
WE HAVE MANY HEROES IN AMERICAN
INDUSTRY WHO STARTED IN THE MAIL
ROOM AND YOU SHARED WITH ME.
THAT YOU ALSO STARTED IN THE
MAIL ROOM AND LOOK LOOK WHERE
YOU HAVE ENDED UP A LOT OF HARD
WORK AND COMMITMENT AND I
IMAGINE FAMILY SUPPORT.
AS WELL ALONG THE WAY -- I JUST
WANT TO ASK A QUESTION THAT --
WE TALKED ABOUT YESTERDAY
BECAUSE I THINK THE COMMITTEE
WOULD FIND IT OF INTEREST.
THE CHALLENGE OF PAY EQUITY --
ENDS.
GENDER DISCRIMINATION IN PAY
EQUITY -- WITH STATE JOBS I
THINK MY BELIEF WAS WELL IF YOU
HAVE A JOB CLASSIFICATION.
ANYONE WITHIN THAT
CLASSIFICATION WOULD RECEIVE THE
SAME COMPENSATION BUT YOU HELP
ME UNDERSTAND IT'S A LITTLE MORE
COMPLICATED THAN THAT AND YOU
TALKED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT.
HELL WORK IS VALUED IN DIFFERENT
CLASSIFICATIONS AND I WONDER IF
YOU COULD JUST SHARE A LITTLE OF
THAT WITH THE COMEDIAN.
YOUR THOUGHTS OF HOW.
WE DO TAKE THAT ON AND IT
SOUNDED A LITTLE MORE
CHALLENGING IN A LITTLE MORE
COMPLEX THAN I MIGHT HAVE
THOUGHT AT THE OUTSET YEAH -- IN
OUR CONVERSATION YESTERDAY --
THE GENDER PAY GAP IS ACTUALLY A
LITTLE BIT COMPLEX FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA BECAUSE SALARIES
ARE SET -- AND IT DOESN'T MATTER
WHICH GENDER -- YOU HAVE
PARTICULAR SALARY HOWEVER WOMEN
HAVE MOSTLY BEEN GEARED TOWARD
CLERICAL AND SOCIAL SCIENCES AND
YESTERDAY I KIND OF GAVE YOU THE
EXAMPLE.
OF OF A DOUBT ADOPTION
SPECIALISTS WHO REQUIRES A
MASTER'S DEGREE -- TO DO THE JOB
DOESN'T RECEIVE AN MSA ON MERRY
SALLY ADJUSTMENT TILL AFTER
TWENTY FOUR MONTHS.
HOWEVER A CORRECTIONAL OFFICER
IN A HIGHWAY PATROL OFFICER ONLY
REQUIRE A HIGH SCHOOL DEGREE AND
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THE
STUDIES THAT WE HAD WITH UC
BERKELEY AND TAX STATE.
THE REPORT SHOWS THAT OTHER
STATES LIKE MINNESOTA AND
WASHINGTON HAD DONE SOME
RESEARCH AND ACTUALLY DID SOME
INFORMATION ABOUT THE VALUE OF
WORK AND HOW.
THE WORK SHE DID.
BE ANALYZED BASED ON THE SKILLS
THE RESPONSIBILITY EFFORT AND
THE WORKPLACE CONDITIONS TO
MEASURE THE VALUE AND TO PROVIDE
AN OPPORTUNITY.
TO IDENTIFY THE GENDER PAY GAP
OR GAPS AND AND FIX THEM
ACCORDINGLY.
I FOUND THAT VERY INTERESTING IN.
IMPLICIT WITHIN THAT COMPARISON
IS THAT A MALE CORRECTIONAL
OFFICER WITH A HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA.
WOULD BE COMPENSATED AT A HIGHER
LEVEL THAN THE ADOPTION
SPECIALIST WITH A MASTER'S
DEGREE -- A FEMALE.
TRADUCTION SPECIALIST IS THAT
THERE'S ACTUALLY A 13% GAP
BETWEEN AN ADOPTION SPECIALISTS
IN A CORRECTIONAL OFFICER AND A
36% GAP BETWEEN ADOPTION
SPECIALIST AND A C. H. P. OFF.
AND HOW DO WE BEGIN TO RECONCILE
THAT WHAT DID YOU LEARN FROM
THESE OTHER STATES EXPERIENCE
ARE THEY AHEAD OF US IN.
TRYING [inaudible]
TO THEY THE QUALITY OF A THINNER.
AND WHAT HAVE YOU LEARNED FROM
THEIR EFFORTS WELL I'VE I'VE
LEARNED THAT -- LOOKING AT THE
VALUE WORK COULD BE EXPENSIVE --
IT'S SOMETHING THAT I THINK THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SHOULD LOOK
AT ALONG WITH NON TRADITIONAL
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS FOR
WOMEN -- THAT WOULD HELP CLOSED
AT THE PAY GAP.
WE ACTUALLY HAVE HAD A COUPLE OF
MENTORSHIP THE I. D..
A PROGRAM THAT WAS SPEARHEADED
BY THE GOVERNMENT AGENCY -- I
BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD ALSO LOOK
INTO A STATEWIDE MENTORSHIP
PROGRAM FOR WOMEN.
THANK YOU AND WE COULD.
PURSUE THIS I HOPE WILL HAVE A
CHANCE.
AS WE WORK WITH THE IN THE
FUTURE AND I THINK WE HAVE THE
RIGHT PERSON FOR THE JOB SO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE.
THANK YOU -- ALONG THOSE LINES
AND THANK YOU SENATOR FOR FOR
STARTING AT LINE OF OF QUESTIONS --
DIALOGUE.
IN TERMS OF AN INCLUSIVE AND
DIVERSE WORK FORCE.
WHAT?
WHAT ARE THE -- MOST EFFECTIVE
STRATEGIES FOR RECRUITMENT THIS
WAS ONE OF OUR STAFF QUESTIONS
IT'S A REALLY GOOD QUESTION
REGARDLESS OF WHERE WE ARE.
IN MANAGEMENT IN THE STATE
WHETHER US AS ELECTED OFFICIALS.
GIVE ME YOUR THOUGHTS A LITTLE
BIT ON THAT.
WELL OF KELLY CHAR IS ACTUALLY
WE HAVE A B. C. P. -- RIGHT NOW
ASKING FOR RESOURCES FOR MORE
RECRUITMENT EFFORTS -- WE HAVE
IN THE PAST TAKEN A PASSIVE ROLE
BECAUSE WE ARE EIGHT PLEASE GIVE
GUIDANCE TO DEPARTMENTS BUT WE
ARE GOING TO BE TAKEN A MORE
PROACTIVE ROLE.
AND I BELIEVE THAT DOING A
LITTLE BIT MORE FOCUS
RECRUITMENT WITH THOSE AREAS
THAT WE ARE UNDER UTILIZED WOULD
BE MORE OF A FICTIVE.
ROACH TO OF PROVIDING DIVERSE
CITY INTO OUR IN OUR WORK STATE
WORK FORCE -- SOME OTHER EFFORTS
THAT HAVE HAPPENED IS TE
REGULATIONS FOR LIKE LEAP
CLASSIFICATIONS FOR DISABLED
PERSONS THERE'S BEEN SOME.
GREAT AT STREAMLINING OF
REGULATION SAYS ACTUALLY HELP IN
THAT AREA TO HAVE MORE DISABLED.
IN OUR WORK FORCE WE'VE ALSO
PARTNERED WITH THE US MARINES
COURT -- AND WE'VE DONE SOME
FOCUS RECRUITMENT DOWN THERE --
TO GET MORE VETERANS INSIDE WE
CREATED A MILITARY SKILLS
TRANSLATOR BITS ON OUR WEBSITE.
AND RIGHT NOW WE WE IT'S GEARED
TOWARDS HIM.
ALL BRANCHES WE WERE GOING TO
ALSO BE I SPREADING OUT THROUGH
THE ARMY THE NAVY AND THE OTHER --
BRANCHES OF THE MILITARY TO TO
SEEK SOME MORE FOCUS RECRUITMENT
IN THAT AREA.
I SAW.
AN A. IN TERMS OF LANGUAGE
CAPABILITIES -- WE ARE
INCREDIBLY DIVERSE AS A STATE.
BUT IT SEEMS --YOU KNOW WE'RE
ALWAYS TALKING ABOUT HOW TO
INCREASE OUR LANGUAGE
CAPABILITIES AND WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT DIVERSE -- INCLUSION AND
RECRUITMENT THEY'RE PROBABLY OUR
COMMUNITIES WERE BETTER FOCUS AN
OUT REACH COULD BE DONE.
I I CAN'T I CAN'T SPEAK TO THE
OUR REQUIREMENT LEVEL IN TERMS
OF EDUCATION BUT WHERE HAVE YOU
SEEN AREAS ARE EVIDENCE WHERE
THERE ARE PARTICULAR PLACES
WHERE WE NEED MORE LANGUAGE
DIVERSITY AND THOUGHTS ON HOW.
TO TO WORK ON THAT.
WELL -- YES AND NO -- WE
ACTUALLY HAVE A ONE EIGHT
HUNDRED LINE FOR ANYONE THAT HAS
ANY ISSUES WITH LANGUAGE AND WE
WILL PROVIDE INTERPRETERS AT THE
STATE EXPERIENCE FOR ANYBODY
THAT.
NEEDS THAT TYPE OF ASSISTANCE --
THE LINE FROM WHAT I UNDERSTAND
WE PROBABLY MAYBE ON AVERAGE GET
FIVE TO TEN CALLS A MONTH --
WHICH SEEMS TO BE KIND OF LOW
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
DO YOU THINK IT'S A MATTER OF
PEOPLE NOT BEING AWARE OF ALL OF
THE NUMBER OR HOW.
TO HOW TO ACCESS THAT COULD BE A
FACTOR OKAY.
THANK YOU AND LASTLY -- I WILL
ASK YOU ABOUT ANOTHER TOPIC THAT
I THINK STAFF -- PROBABLY
BROUGHT UP AS AN ISSUE.
AND THAT'S THE THE ISSUE OF OF
AN ANTI NEPOTISM POLICY.
AND YOUR **** I MEAN IF THEY IF
THEY I'M SURE IT'S HARD IN
VARIOUS PARTS OF THE STATE -- I
WOULD THINK SACRAMENTO -- ONE WE
RECRUIT FROM WHERE OR FROM
COMMUNITIES OF WHICH WE KNOW I
GUESS BUT YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE
ON THE ANTI NEPOTISM POLICY AND
CERTAINLY WITH THE GOVERNORS
ANNOUNCED EXPANSION OF THE PROBE
AT THE I. ARE -- WHAT SHOULD BE
DONE TO REALLY ENSURE THAT ALL
THE DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES ARE
ACTUALLY AT HERRING TO THAT
POLICY?
WELL AND ACTUALLY YES THE
NEPOTISM ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN
IN THE PAPER OF LATE I HAVE BEEN
QUITE DISTURBING -- CAL HR DOES
HAVE A GUIDELINE POLICY THAT
ASSISTS DEPARTMENTS ON HOW TO
CREATE NEPOTISM POLICIES.
WHAT CAL HR?
HISTORICALLY HAS IT BEEN A
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY.
WE DO PARTNER WITH OUR SISTER
AGENCIES STATE PERSONNEL BOARD
WHO HAS OVERSIGHT OF COMPLIANCE
REVIEW AND THEY ACTUALLY.
CHECK IN COMPLIANCE REVIEW EVERY
DEPARTMENT. TO SEE THAT THEY
HAVE A NEPOTISM POLICY.
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OBVIOUSLY YOU'VE GOT A BROAD
RANGE OF ISSUES YOU HAVE TO DEAL
WITH -- ALONG WITH MY COLLEAGUES
I WANT TO COMMEND YOU -- FOR
YOUR HISTORY BY THE WAY I
ASPIRED TO WORK IN THE MAIL ROOM --
BUT THAT'S A DIFFERENT STORY --
LET ME ASK THERE'S CLEARLY A
NUMBER FOLKS HERE TO SUPPORT YOU
LET ME ASK FOLKS WHO WOULD LIKE
TO COME FORWARD.
AND SUPPORT -- TO IT.
COME TO THE MIKE IF YOU WOULD
LIKE.
TO OKAY I SEE A LOT OF HAPPY
FACES SO I'M SURE THEY'RE JUST
SILENTLY HAPPY -- ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION.
I DIDN'T THINK SO SO HI.
HI THAT IS YOUR CUE SENATOR ROTH
HAS MADE THE MOTION MADAM
SECRETARY.
SENATORS BATES HI BATES ONLINE
MORNING MORNING I ROSS.
ROSS I WILL.
ATKINS I BY THAT PASSES
UNANIMOUSLY OF MEMBERS PRESENT
MISTER WELK IS ABSENT --
CONGRATULATIONS AND THANK
[inaudible]
YEAH.
WELL THANK YOU EVERYONE -- I
HOPE -- IT JUST TO TELL YOU --
THEY DON'T GO QUICKLY THIS
QUICKLY ALL THE TIME.
YOU SHOULD KNOW THAT.
WE'RE GONNA GET LULLED INTO A
SENSE OF HI EXPERTISE COME IN
BEFORE THIS BODY BUT WE
CONGRATULATE YOU AND AND THANK
YOU AND YOUR FRIENDS AND FAMILY.
FOR BEING HERE WITH THE AD.
WE WILL ADJOURN INTO EXECUTIVE
SESSION